- To me, art is like a gift, you know?
If you have capacity, if you have talent,
if you have grit and hard work
and you want to produce,
gifts are supposed to be given.
So what's the point of giving a gift
if no one gets it, right?
What's the point of producing a symphony
if no one gets to hear it?
So I think reception is important
to give the art point,
meaning, as opposed to pointless.
You know?
Otherwise, you're just
decorating your home.
Now, we could have a debate whether
I'm receiving it myself, right?
So we could definitely debate that.
But
I think,
and maybe this is just the romantic in me,
it has to be enjoyed.
And maybe one person is fine.
Maybe if you hang it in your own home
and it's just for you, that's fine too.
But I think art has to be enjoyed,
otherwise what's the point?
You know?
Otherwise it's just therapy, you know?
I'm just painting for therapy.
And we all do things like that, you know?
Art has to have another
human being involved.
Or to me, art is about
a relationship, right?
You can't call yourself a romantic
or somebody who chooses to love another
if nobody ever feels your love.
You know?
It's, I think art is,
it's a type of language, right?
I know
people
who
are the world's worst communicators
when it comes to their emotions
when you have a conversation with them.
I've dated some of them.
But given the opportunity to write,
it's magical.
And the feelings pour out on the page
in an eloquence like I've never seen.
And as everyone here knows,
great art in some way, shape, or form
is always personal or
semi-autobiographical.
It's too hard to write
pure fiction, you know?
We put ourselves in it
because it gives it a sense of reality
and it's what makes us passionate
for the subject that we're tackling.
I know dancers who, you know,
you meet them and they're like this
but as soon as they start dancing,
you realize it's all there.
So, art is language.
And if no one hears you,
you know if a tree falls in the woods,
you know, if no one
hears what you're saying,
is it worth saying anything?
They're just thoughts.
So what's the point of writing a play
that never gets shown?
It's just a thought, you know?
It's just an intention.
So, yeah no, I think it must be shared.
It's one of the ways in
which people communicate.